An architect's dream
is firstly
to be identified by
developers with major projects
- that is
what all of us want -
and then there's the exploratory,
detective work
which aims to capture the essence of the location:
What the site
chosen by the main developer
can,
or cannot offer.
Well, there is something curious about this site,
by the rue de la Loi,
which is - let's face it -
a car-filled sewer...
Look at where similar buildings are found
around the world...
usually at the end
of a lengthy vista,
flanked by umpteen rows of trees,
and facing due south,
carefully designed
to catch the eye.
But the Council is staying put,
at the heart of this area.
Alongside a road
with little architectural merit.
Surrounded by functional buildings.
It's moving... in its modest way.
It certainly moved me;
I found it astonishing,
to put such an important building
in such an incongruous place....
so that was my starting-point.
The site is occupied by a building
that is one of Brussels' cultural landmarks:
the Résidence Palace.
From the start I was determined
to try to save
most of the features
of the historical part of the building.
We looked,
in some detail,
at what this old carcass
could still offer.
It was immediately clear
that what was needed was a cube.
There could be no half measures
or concessions on the shape,
no frills and spills.
Because all that would have spoilt
the symbolic aspect of this cube.
It's a box, and a box is,
by definition, something that you open,
otherwise it's a block.
We had to make these façades "breathe".
And that was when it came to me...
We will make one façade
from old, recycled oak frames,
the sort you can find these days
in containers
in streets all over Europe.
That allows us to send
a number of messages at once:
diversity - patchwork - unity,
after all, they are all frames
and they all have the same function,
all made of the same material - oak -
which you can find anywhere in Europe.
and, what's more, there's the need to recycle.
What's going to be the main concern
for our children and grandchildren?
It's clearly those questions - environmental questions -
that will come first.
And they'll be tackled in a much more generous,
inspiring, spontaneous way...
than our current,
remarkably timid approach.
When we needed to get down
to the final preparations,
the first idea I had was
to make an open vase,
like a corolla of flowers.
That was the first sketch.
And then we started
looking at the surface,
which led, bit by bit,
to its becoming what was called,
firstly, a callipygian goddess,
until it assumed its current form
which is being described as a "heart".